[Music]
I won the Kickball Championship last we
heard but you won oh well do you see my
my injury I heard that dude took you out
yeah he threw it out my [__] nut yeah
yeah what happened so I was rounding
third Bas wait hold on let's give the
people some context so uh the TMG Studio
you know oh I have a good story for you
too Talent producers everybody we uh
they participate in a kickball league
it's the third entrance mhm you know
it's tmg's thirdd entrance into the
league MH and they took the dub last
night they won the league won it all
Round of Applause
folks
wow and then I took a picture with uh
the loser of the team we beat last night
too that's Petty as [__] what do you
mean we're doing high fives yeah we're
doing high fives and then I high five
and she Taps me she goes can I get a
picture with you and like she's passing
me I was like yeah oh and like so then
after we the high fives end I come back
around and I take a picture of her I
thought you just hopped in I thought you
went up to the losing team and said
let's get a picture it was a good game
didn't you say you took a picture with
the loser of the losing team I mean no
she the worst one no no no no just just
a girl on the team okay she's a fan of
you and you just called her a [__]
loser you said that no she she was nice
she was a great singer W wait did you
did you hear what Ryan said no before
Ryan can I tell the story with the
gloves
he's up so I'm good then yeah tell it oh
yes the GL
story running down no no no no don't
tell the glove story um we can cut it
out if he doesn't want me to tell it but
so I used to okay so I like when I first
moved to SF I joined one of these
leagues CU it's like a good excuse to
meet people or whatever so we would play
and then everyone would go out for beers
afterwards and it was like a social
thing so I was asking Ryan I was like
did you guys do you guys go out after
this like you play the teams and go out
and he was like
no some of them are very mean yeah and
I'm like what do you mean they're mean
he's like they're just like there's you
know there there's some of them are just
like mean they're like not nice people
and I was like what do you mean and
apparently they were some have been
bullying him Ryan every team every team
cuz he wears he wears gloves I mean it
looks ridiculous catcher gloves Joan so
he so Ryan okay so last let me tell the
story first go ahead so he he has these
gloves and he wears them and I guess
like there's like these 22-year-old kids
that make fun of him for it on the
opposite teams so one time he missed the
ball and one of the kids goes guess
you're going to need new
[Laughter]
gloves so this this has been happening I
was like dude you kind of got [__]
owned this has been happening every game
and he plays first base so the visiting
team is sitting right there and he just
hears it like every
inning
Ryan but he also hurt his back last
night did you tell you guys that no yeah
he hurt his back so that's why Jawan is
wearing gloves cuz he had a sit out in
the championship game a what yeah dude I
felt really bad bummer ah faucet inj
wait sure he hurt his back no he heard
it pretty bad I think his self-esteem
might be a little damaged I think that's
what it is you know are you one of the
bullies no no no I'm just I'm not on the
bully side at all I'm saying it's you
know it's tough to be out there dealing
with [__] [__] kids you know when
you're just trying to casat the ball I
would love it if you were out there and
you got bullied somehow some way I
probably would I probably would Ryan you
need to give it back yeah going to need
some new gloves yeah I will when I shove
it up your mom's ass he said it he said
something about like uh that would work
honestly that would work uncomfortable
yeah yeah exactly it's like ew what yeah
I'm need some new gloves when I put my
fist in your ass yeah
yeah Tee's like okay you're hot I want
to fist you oh dude stop man or or you
make it a that was a good
one
great
joke I'm gonna [__] kill
you what I'm going to follow you home
and [__] murder
you all right man I'm just playing I'm
just playing with these gloves cut you
into [__] pieces bro I don't know
what these gloves can do yeah he's just
on first base with the first basem like
guy next to them he just like saying all
this [__] to I'm going to [__] murder
you you understand me yeah the kid makes
the first basement R's like oh good job
you know there's no fingerprints when I
wear these righto
yeah this is my lovely producer Alex who
mind you has had concussions from
playing D3
soccer how do how do he broke his wrist
in kickball yeah also yep and this
season yeah last whatever and what does
he do when they
win oh my God are you okay all right
guys what's up as big as this kid's head
is he can't get a [__] beer can open
dude he's laughing it off right now but
I bet that [__] did some damage right
there Alex I don't think so I don't know
if it's possible to damage Alex's skull
I love him to death he was on sheer
adrenaline after winning the
championship game and like looking at
this the day after like that was so
[__]
stupid play play playit Play It Again
run from the start I'm not in on this
anymore want
me oh my
God can you slow-mo
that look at his wind up
oh he put his back into the first
one doing a bicep
curl that's why I hired him I knew in
the interview actually I was like is
that a can of truly behind you he's like
but yeah I'm like slam it on your
[__] face he's like yeah no problem
I'm like winner you're locked dude he is
in concussion protocol yeah Sports
reference yeah yeah dude that is nuts
and then he slammed it on the fence
after don't don't say that's nuts around
Zach that's not cool sorry that is wild
that's nut that's nuts that is nuts oh
yeah the guy threw the ball at my nut so
that was that was the thing I was trying
to bring up yeah I was rounding third
base I got caught off like way too far I
tried scrambling back the guy [__]
runs up to me dude is like 65 or
whatever ripped and just Chucks it out
my nut yeah it was aggressive oh what if
you had like some anime line leading up
I heard you could use another
ball some Transformers
L I'm bully I'm bulli yeah but you bully
back no I don't that is not true I don't
think I
do what I just asked bad questions is
that bullying in in a way yeah you
prompt it okay like you'll walk out to
people and you're like oh I didn't
realize you're so small yeah that's true
I did a Jay and Trey episode on their
random Mort show and uh before the
episode started I noticed uh Trey was
missing a tooth yeah and the first thing
I I haven't seen him in a while I was
like I asking I was like dude where the
[__] your tooth and he was like and he
had a cavity that was pulled and he he's
like super self-conscious about he was
he it's been missing for like three
months and he was like I don't know he's
like so you don't watch my show at all
cuz like I've been referencing this
tooth like every [__]
episode I was like oh yeah yeah damn
Zach yeah so you bully unintentionally
yeah I was bullied a lot in high not it
was friend bullied you know the friend
group I was like the Ryan of the friend
group TMG got it yeah damn Ryan we got
to fix this man he's your guys well Ry
Ryan got bullied in high school he
discovered this on stretch and fade we
were going in on his shoes and then he
was like I was bullying a lot in high
school we're like oh
God what were you saying about his shoes
they suck
J